is there anything that seems
particularly different about the current
time that we're living through that
seems to be an outlier based on the
patterns and connections that you've
studied so deeply in preparing all of
the books that you've written when you
consume so much material in history it
kind of changes how you think
and so a lot of people nowadays who
don't read a lot of history quite
frankly have this idea that everything
that's going on now is new and different
and modern it's never happened before
there's the old cliche in in financial
bubbles that this time it's different
you know like in 2008 with the new way
of doing a real estate equities that are
This Time It's Different you know with
AI This Time It's Different it's never
different it's the same patterns
repeating over and over and over again
throughout history